le 19 décembre dernier jean pierre
pernaut présenté pour la toute dernière
fois de sa carrière son célèbre journal
de 13 heures mesdames et messieurs
bonjour ça y est c'est fait c'était la
dernière fois que je vous le disais
prétend profiter d'une paisible retraite
le journaliste a décidé de quitter son
siège en plein succès un succès qui
s'est confirmée avec l'odeur
stratosphérique de ce tout dernier jt
qui a réuni 8,1 millions téléspectateurs
soit 59% des français présents devant
leur écran jean pierre pernaut qui a été
remplacé le temps des vacances par son
joker habituel jacques legros c'est donc
aujourd'hui que sa remplaçante officiel
marie sophie lacarrau transfuge de pense
que prenait ses fonctions pour la toute
première fois
bonjour est très heureuse de vous
accompagner à partir d'aujourd'hui pas
tout premier jt durant lequel la
journaliste a décidé d'adresser aux
téléspectateurs du journal un petit
message ainsi qu'à jean pierre j'espère
bien tissée au plus vite avec vous ces
mêmes liens de complicité et de
confiance que vous avez pu faire grandir
avec jean pierre pernaut pendant 33 ans
alors premier jt de marie sophie
lacarrau est elle à la hauteur
et oui premier jt de marie sophie
lacarrau alors c'est à dire j'adore
cette jeune fille rien à manger aux
voilà j'ai échangé avec elle paris
serait ce parce qu'elle présentait une
émission voilà sur france 2 exceptionnel
prodige qui était produit par endemol
productions et c'est vrai que elle va
manquer dans cette émission
marie sophie lacarrau déjà ma natte jean
pierre pernaut c'était être en compte ma
mère c'était le premier lundi où jean
pierre de meule c'est incroyable mois
les années
ce matin jean pierre pernaut la clv il a
fait quoi c'est sympa mais france elle à
20h40 en direct pour ses enfants et pour
moi c'était très drôle ce qui était déjà
commis quand il s'est levé ce matin il
s'est levé vers 9h à savoir est ce qui
m'a fait rire c'est que il a vu la
lumière dans la chambre de sa fille il
va leur achat me film était déjà levé
mais papa je suis je suis en train de
travailler pour pour l'école
elle était en en résidentiel mais voilà
donc c'était comique sans fin mais oui
c'est vrai c'était et puis prendre son
petit déjeuner prendre son temps non
c'était vraiment très agréable et vous
qui lui avez vu aujourd'hui mon moi sa
luge érige votre avis oui mais tu sais
quoi
il aurait vu le venir mais aujourd'hui
c'était un peu compliqué il m'a
accompagné pour venir ici alors je vais
vous dire quelque chose
je vais très bien ce club et je le dis
et c'est pour ça que j'aime aussi ce
jean pierre qui est un garçon vraiment
île aux seychelles aime énormément
il a la classe on voulait l'invité
aujourd'hui pour faire le débrief aussi
du journal de marie sophie lacarrau
l'avoir sur zoom et jean pierre a dit
aujourd'hui c'est le jour de
marie-sophie ne veut pas lui prendre la
vedette
donc tu veux pas intervenir sur aucune
émission aujourd'hui on parle de marie
sophie lacarrau je veux qu'on parle de
son journal et moi voilà vont m'oublier
les séries pour l'instant je le ferai à
jour voilà j'aimerai vous voir quand
vous voulez parce que je vous aime bien
mais c'est vraiment la classe voilà
c'est un beau monument bmci l'excès pour
s'amener avec lui moi mais non mon année
qui semble être un blizzard de joker
pardon est-ce qu'il a regardé le propre
piano évidemment ils avaient le coeur
qui palpite est à fond mais il avait il
avait une peur pour elle ça qui était
émouvant exception ouais et je pense que
ça lui ça lui a redonné des souvenirs de
son démarrage du 13h et franchement
franchement au début on a trouvé stressé
ce qui est normal parce qu'elle a une
énorme pression et on l'a trouvée
parfaite alors on était très bien elle
était dans le ton comme jean-pierre elle
était formidable elle était pétillante
ils ont gardé ils ont gardé la même la
même lignée que fait jean pierre et non
j'ai alors regardé justement vous avez
un petit comparatif entre jean pierre
pernaut et marie sophie lacarrau rire
mesdames et messieurs bonjour ravi de
vous retrouver bonne année permettez moi
à mon tour de vous présenter tous mes
voeux pour cette année 2020 du fond du
coeur
bonjour est très heureuse de vous
accompagner à partir d'aujourd'hui pour
vous informer tous les jours de la
semaine à 13h premiers flocons par
exemple ce matin en isère il devait
tomber partout en montagne cette semaine
abbès galles jarret quincy russell en
auvergne ce lundi moins 8 degrés au
réveil qu'il fallait vraiment sortir
bien emmitouflés abbès dans le puy de
dome guillaume fric son et céline olive
je vous souhaite encore une très bonne
année à tous merci pour votre immense
finalité bon après midi et demain
c'est un très bon après midi et je vous
dis à demain et oui alors le cas très
bien très bien
je vous aime beaucoup ses très belles en
solaire lumineuse on a vraiment envie de
l'écouter de la suivre elle est
effectivement tu as dit nathalie au
début il était un tout petit peu
stressant y avait des trémolos dans sa
voilà un petit peu normal mais au
contraire sûr que c'est hyper mignon
parce qu'il ya un truc justement qui
n'est pas formaté c'est pas une sorte de
machine de guerre il ya aussi de
l'affectif c'est super dur de prendre la
place de jean-pierre sueur et je trouve
qu'elle a elle a vraiment très très bien
réussi cette prime natalia ce qui lui a
donné des conseils jean pierre est ce
qu'il appelait pendant les vacances ski
sol non pas dans les vacances non
voyants pied quand on était en vacances
à vacances mais ce matin comme ils ont
téléphoné à jean pierre pourrait
demander s'il avait vu le le conducteur
non effet basons pas vrai pouvoir les
sujets ouais ouais son équipe mais ce qu
est ce que tu as vu voilà c'est mieux
c'est un vrai scoop et donc jean-pierre
la débat n'en fait confiance à marie
sony passe et j'ai rien à dire et je lui
fais confiance et je sais que de toute
façon ça sera très très bien et il a eu
raison
et c'était commune par contre après
quand c'était terminé c'était très
mignon parce que elle lui a envoyé un
texto en lui disant qu'elle a énormément
penser à lui
émerger des grands tout j'ai trouvé
bensalah jean pierre sophie attention
c'est là toute la quantité pas évident
c'est que sur l'a2 quand même il ya eu
le nouveau ce qui est beau c'est du
copié-collé ailleurs qu'il est beau il
est généralement moi quand je regarde
quand encore quand je regarde un paquet
de biscuits j'achète donc ça c'est juste
pour revenir sur une pierre qui a aussi
été très classe parce que pour sa
première c'est la première fois qu'il a
intronisé justement marie sophie
lacarrau quand il est parti à 13 heures
il lui a laissé un tweet aujourd'hui
pour l'encourager donc il est très
classe et à l'eau si elle avait la fin
l'actif et btv et regarder la classe ça
a été quand ils sont passés là vous
regardez regardez pas le faire pour eux
marie-sophie c'est un honneur de vivre
ce moment avec toi avec les équiper avec
les téléspectateurs
et oui parce que tu seras le 4 janvier
tu viens de france télévisions mais tu
viens surtout de villefranche de
rouergue ardennais d'abord l'aveyron
l'accent de la garder un petit peu
abdallah ya un arthur qu on disait qu'on
devait le garder le garder cela sinon en
renier notre coeur bon courage pour la
suite
merci jean pierre méan suis riche de
tout ce que tu viens de nous montrer ses
prix des notes moi depuis tout à l'heure
j'ai bien compris quelle est ma ma
feuille de route et si tu veux bien
eh ben j'ai bientôt lancer génériques et
ben non
ouais alors j'ai l'impression chaud
attention achtung achtung pensé moi j'ai
pas été convaincus par marie sophie
lacarrau alors là sa décharge il faut
savoir qu'en 87 quand jean pierre
pernaut a pris le relais d'yves mourousi
une énorme star personne n'y croyait
tout le monde aime ça n'allait pas durer
et finalement ils s'installent et donc
elle s'installer mais le problème c'est
qu'on la connaît déjà à la tête d'un
journal marie sophie lacarrau et je
serais incapable de vous dire son style
c'est quoi le style marie sophie grassin
aujourd'hui non mais c'est vrai que jean
pierre pernaut s'est identifié c'est les
régions l on sait maintenant ce que ça
encore dit
c'est une journaliste régional ou encore
direct a dit un truc droit mais de toute
façon elle n'a pas le choix puisque les
l'empreinte du journal de 13 heures de
jean pierre pernaut elle est mort ce si
elle ne fait pas à trop guillemets 2
jean pierre bel moi je les trouvais sl à
la hauteur oui et elle sera l'heureuse
louis était le sympathique oui quelque
part moi c'est vrai que j'ai l'habitude
d'un présentateur sommes au trésor et
que j'ai tant pis pour le féminisme et
je préfère un présentateur hommes elle
dit ce qu'elle pense ma chérie on va
voir les adieux de jean pierre pernaut
moi je vous envie de le revoir
c'est un des sujets qui a été le plus
commenté mouvance je sais que je vais
lâcher une larmichette je voulais vous
avez pleuré
alors on a beaucoup pleuré tous en
coulisses ce qui était vraiment ce que
vous lui avez fait un coup vous lui avez
dit que vous seriez pas là vous partiez
déjà au plus du choc
alors c'est son premier coup de
téléphone ça a été tout de suite à moi
en lisant mes chéris merci infiniment
jamais j'aurais pensé que tu serais mis
au trésor parce que tu m'as dit que tu
avais un train à prendre à midi c'est la
toucher et non il avait un doute sur les
enfants d'accord mais il m'a dit sur toi
chérie jamais j'ai écrit et ça a été ma
pub c'était touchant pour moi ça a été
ma plus belle surprise pour le 13h vous
avez pleuré en sortant dans le taxi oui
c'était je sais mon fils il parce
qu'après j'ai je devais partir mon fils
j'ai ce qui paraît il a pleuré pleuré on
a dû à une console est tellement qu'il
pleurait c'était très surprenante parce
que mon fils si ni quand même voilà si
là il va pleurer va pleurer dans son lit
mais il montre jamais rien mon fils est
et non je vous étiez pas là le lendemain
vous n'avez pas dormi avec jean-pierre
son label en train de faire me sens et
oui ou non le surlendemain vous êtes
rentrer à la maison après le puy du fou
je reste et a dormi au puy du fou non
mais oui mais oui petit parti en
vacances ah ouais donc vous avez des le
rejoindre raconte oui vous avez dormi
avec lui combine deux soirs après je
calcul bien donc vendredi soir n'auront
lundi soir non dimanche soit lundi soir
non trois fois après ses trois seules
soir seul a pris aux légitimes
ouais ça ne c'est horrible ses origines
jamais je peux laisser passer ça et
quand il s'est réveillé le premier matin
qu'est-ce que vous ont dit les enfants
est malheureusement je les ai pas vus
jeudi au puy du fou avec d'accord bah
écoutez voici quelques tacles plus de
foudre été acceptée parce qu'ils
allaient partir en vacances en france il
existe et fonctionne avec s'était placé
les hommes d'affaires les dockers
regarde tout ce bref en trois ans avec
vous on a créé des liens très forts je
voudrais vous dire que j ai mis toute ma
passion pendant passé la moitié de ma
vie où le savez c'était un honneur
pouvoir traverser la petite la grande
histoire du monde grâce à vous à votre
fidélité
donc j'arrête à moins qu'à mon âge on
peut avoir envie d'un autre rythme j'ai
une pensée pour ma femme qui était là
tout à l'heure pour ma mère qui pendant
30 ans n'a jamais manqué et je craque
elle n'a jamais manqué un journal local
sans doute de là haut où je vous avais
pas pour autant merci à tous je vous
embrasse du fond du coeur merci je vous
aime je vous oublierai jamais à toi de
jouer marie-sophie shutter island est
petit
sa mère ça assez émouvant kwapis des
l'émouvant ilan nul et il était
tellement vrai et c'est jean pierre
pastori jamais ce genre énorme est avec
toi
[Rires]